hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde da ist die letzte Mal so gut bei
euch ankamen spielen wir heute
tatsächlich mal wieder sketchfull mit
der Luke Crew es geht los mit Runde
Nummer eins und mir als Maler Atom
schüchtern und Seilbahn ich würde sagen
wir nehmen die Seilbahn das sollte
relativ einfach sein wir malen dafür
einfach einen Fluss der geht
beispielsweise hier so lang zack zack
und hier vorne ist die andere Seite dann
nehmen wir einen Film einmal zack haben
hier vorne grün und hier vorne grün und
hatte rüber müssen wir jetzt eine
Seilbahnen da mache ich erstmal hier
einen Turm so zack zack zack und hier
die andere Seite zack zack zack zack
zack zack über ein Seil fährt eine Bahn
hier ist die Bahn die ersten haben schon
das ist ein paar Menschen sind auch zack
zack zack und es geht meine Damen und
Herren genau da rum
ich sag euch besser kann man nicht malen
doch lukas hat es nicht erraten fast
meinen Namen aber so blöd oder wie Malin
ist am Zeichnen es hat sechs Buchstaben
oh
[Musik]
Stock hat fünf Buchstaben
fuckel ey da ist der Minecraft Spieler
am Start ich sag's wie selbst komm mal
runter weiter geht's mit Jessie das Wort
hatten paar mehr Buchstaben das ist eine
Banane tatsächlich eine Banane ist nicht
braun das kann das sind auch ein
Croissant
[Musik]
Leute heute wird absolut rasiert und
damit nämlich nicht mal nicht
vorhandenen Bad mona ist am Zeichnen und
zwar zeichnet sie eine Sonne in die
obere linke Ecke eine Wolke aber es hat
vier Buchstaben was soll das dann sein
Luft vielleicht nee Luft kann man noch
schwer zeichnen irgendwas schwarzes
Möbel nee Möwe ist auch nicht Vogel okay
irgendwas auf dem Boden das ist auf
jeden Fall ein Haus ein Haus vielleicht
nee Dach ein Dach ein Dach ich hab's
erster Platz meine Damen und Herren
erster Platz und wisst ihr was für mich
auch den ersten Platz belegt die
Handyhüllen von Rhinos ihr wisst ja dass
ich reiner Shield Hüllen schon seit eh
und ihr benutze jahrelange Erfahrungen
damit habe und weiß es ist wirklich die
besten Cases sind die es überhaupt gibt
von daher danke danke dass ich wieder
mit euch zusammenarbeiten darf denn
reiner Shield hat natürlich nicht nur
ganz kleine schwarze Höhlen und Tausende
von anderen Designs sondern neuerdings
auch seit ein paar Tagen eine
Kooperation mit Naruto
[Musik]
dieser Trailer könnten Kinofilm Trailer
sein aber die bewerben damit einfach
eine verdammte Handyhülle also meine
Damen und Herren wenn euch das gefällt
dann schaut gerne mal auf der Website
von rhinoshield vorbei in Link findet
ihr unten in der Videobeschreibung und
mit dem Code Luca erhaltet ihr auch noch
mal 15 % auf alles allerdings nur bis
zum 6 Januar also seid schnell vorbei es
gibt unzählige Designs die euch auch
teilweise selber zusammenstellen könnt
und so von daher danke schön an meine
Schild für sponsern des heutigen Videos
und wenn man jetzt ganz schnell weiter
mit Sketch wohl hier haben wir eine
Katze tatsächlich ey ich bin Ehre ich
errate alles direkt wir haben heute
übrigens auch nur sechs Leute am Start
das letzte Mal schon ein bisschen lang
gedauert hat und ich will ein bisschen
öfter Zeichner ich muss zeichnen und ich
habe als Auswahl Weste Stoßstange und
Fred Feuerstein okay wir nehmen auf
jeden Fall die beste dementsprechend mal
ich erstmal mich hier zack zack Kerl äh
hier mit meinem Körper
so mit meinen Beinen natürlich
und hier mit meinen Händen der bitte
bitte
einfach Luca reinschreiben würde naja es
geht aber um was anderes und zwar um die
beste ich meine jetzt einfach mal blau
zack zack zack
so jetzt machen wir das immer so ein
bisschen an damit die Leute auch checken
dass es wirklich nur um das hier heute
geht nur um dieses Kleidungsstück meine
Damen und Herren ich kann ja auch noch
mal kurz zum Reißverschluss dran machen
mit so Knöpfen dass dies checken das ist
jetzt kein normales T-Shirt ist oder so
allerdings haben es auch schon zwei
Leute erraten und zwar Mona und mal in
die drei in jeder ne es sind diese drei
Fanpage von mir die auch immer dieses
diese Quiz ist erstellen die
telefonieren schon wieder ich sag's wie
es ist um mich zu erkennen brauche ich
vielleicht auch noch blonde Haare obwohl
meine Haare gar nicht mehr so richtig
blond sind
es ist mehr so ein Braun irgendwie
geworden über die Zeit jeder zerraten
und ich bin immer noch
auf dem Herz Wort hat extrem viele
Buchstaben und sie zeichnet auch so ein
bisschen
Kinder Schokolade
[Musik]
ich bin kein Mensch fünf Buchstaben hat
dieses Wort hier und es ist etwas mit
zwei Beinen oder was ist denn das ein
Sessel nee eine Couch nee nicht ein
Couchen ich war zwar nicht der erste
Blick immer noch den ersten Platz ist
gar nicht mal so schlecht gezeichnet
mittlerweile achtet ihr tatsächlich auch
auf so Details das in den Kissen nicht
nur der Hintergrund ist von dem Link
eigentlich würde ich das aber ein Rot
sehen ja eine Couch aber man kann es
wirklich erkennen hier ist ein Sack oder
irgendwie sowas oder dann wollte oder
was ist denn das ist auch noch blau okay
es ist ein es könnte ein Topf sein aber
ein Topf hat weniger Buchstaben
irgendwas mit einem Haar aber ich habe
gar keine Ahnung
ich dachte irgendwas mit Wasser ist ein
Fisch Gold auch Goldfisch
[Musik]
mal doch einfach den Fisch anstatt
erstmal die Hälfte der Zeit damit zu
verschwenden dass er so einen komischen
Topf damals das hier wird als nächstes
gemalt das könnten Wellen sein nee wir
haben Schnee
[Musik]
oh mein Gott wie schnell ist plötzlich
alle erraten einfach ja da kann man auch
einfach klatschen dicker hier wird
wieder irgendwas mit Schnee gemalt
vielleicht Schneeflocke nee ist falsch
Flocken nee
Eiszeit nee sie meinten Tee es könnten
das sein Fäh was soll das sein Schnee
Eiszapfen das soll ein Dach sein von
einem Haus da hinten ach so okay okay
letzte Runde meine Damen und Herren ich
habe als Auswahl Bühne Frankreich und
Skrillex ich würde sagen wir nehmen
Frankreich äh zeichnet erstmal die
Silhouette das sieht ja irgendwie
so aus
zeichnen dann die Flagge
ja glaube ich
so aussieht wartet mal das sollte die
Frankreich Flagge sein
Mama vielleicht noch einen Baguette so
zack zack zack zack da machen wir
vielleicht noch den Eiffelturm zack zack
zack zack das können wir noch mal in
Frankreich wir haben was gibt's denn da
noch die Mona Lisa so so so so so dass
diese komische Frau drauf
dann hat sie natürlich auch noch Augen
zack zack ey sorry aber besser kann man
sich malen
ich mache noch hier
ich bin einfach wirklich ein Profi
definitiv nein
[Musik]
die letzte Runde ich sag euch ich halte
den ersten Platz schon wieder ein extrem
langes Wort was hier auf uns wartet das
ist ein Weihnachtsbaum
hier haben wir irgendwas grünes was
komplett wir war gezeichnet wird jetzt
mit einer anderen Farbe drauf
was ist denn das ist das
[Musik]
was ist da ist das eine Krone nee auch
wieder eine Couch erraten
in Teich das sollen Teich sein und die
letzte Runde meine Damen und Herren Jana
zeichnet gerade ist das vielleicht ein
Pärchen wenn man so macht nee dem Fall
mit zwei gelbe Kreise sich lieben Monat
sehr raten corporate Walcher keine
Ahnung wer das ist auch erraten wir
haben Liebe Beziehung das ist eine
Beziehung
was passiert denn
[Musik]
aber ich habe den ersten Platz ich habe
den ersten Platz
meine Damen und Herren wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann lasst gern einen
Daumen hoch unter dem Video da abonniert
meinen Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke
und weitere Videos nicht zu verpassen
danke schön noch mal nur eine Shield
dass sie das heutige Video
freundlicherweise unterstützt haben ihr
wisst ich nutze diese Scheiße seit
tausenden von Jahren von daher danke
danke an euer stetiges Vertrauen und wir
sehen uns morgen wieder einen neuen
Video wieder tschüss